Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Ich habe gerade den Faden verloren. Ich bin immer noch total fasziniert davon, dass es so einfach sein soll mit dem UKW.
Wir müssen es mal machen.
Wir können doch mal einen Datengarten demnächst machen. Also Donnerstags im Chaos Computer Club Berlin.
Der Aufwand ist es halt immer, diese Bausätze vorzubereiten.
Im Vorbereitungstag hast du vorhin auch gerade bei der Frage zur Illegalität des UKWs mit einem Buch von 1939 gewedelt.
Genau. Ja, bis 1996 galt ein Gesetz aus dem Dritten Reich. Das Gesetz wurde erlassen 1937 und sah Zuchthaus, schweres Zuchthaus, bis zu drei Jahren für das Senden oder auch nur den Besitz eines Senders, selbst wenn der nicht funktionsfähig ist. Also nur Teile davon.
Wobei zu klären wäre, was schweres Zuchthaus noch ist. Das ist noch unklar.
Das entzieht sich meiner Kenntnis, aber ich weiß, es gab auch Gefängnisstrafe. Ich würde mal vermuten, dass man da in einem Wasserloch hockt, das irgendwie zur Hälfte mit Matsch und mit Wasser gefüllt war. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht kann es da jemand drüber aufklären.
0-3-3-1-77-97-0, falls ihr schon mal in einem Zuchthaus wart oder wisst, was das ist?
Schweres Zuchthaus.
Schweres Zuchthaus, genau.
Es wurde in den 70er Jahren sowohl in der DDR als auch in der Bundesrepublik wurde das sehr drastisch verfolgt. Es gab unter anderem Berlin Sonderkommissionen, die versucht haben, Leute zu ermitteln, die aus politischen Gründen in Berlin illegale Sendungen gemacht haben, was natürlich in der DDR nochmal einen ganz besonderen Geschmack hatte. Also die Leute, die da in Prenzlauer Berg frühe beratenden Radio gemacht haben, die können da Geschichten von erzählen. Seit 1996 ist es eine Ordnungswidrigkeit, die im Prinzip bestraft werden kann, bis zu einer halben Million Euro. Aber die ganzen Leute, die sowas als Hobby machen und dabei erwischt werden, die zahlen zwischen 500 und 2500 Euro.
Und machen dann weiter?
Manche Leute wüssten gar nicht, dass es illegal ist. Tatsächlich? Typisch mal. Manche Leute machen das vielleicht genau deshalb, weil es da einen bestimmten Reiz gibt. Von Höherstrafen weiß ich nichts. Die Sender werden natürlich beschlagnahmt, obwohl das eigentlich illegal ist.
Du meinst, die 2-Dollar-Sender werden beschlagnahmt? Wieso ist es illegal, die illegalen Sender zu beschlagnahmen? Das hab ich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden.
Weil der Besitz dieser Geräte und der Bau dieser Geräte nicht mehr verboten ist. Also dafür riskiert man nicht mehr ein schweres Zuchthaus.
Forschungszwecken kannst du das doch bauen. Forschung ist erlaubt in Deutschland.
Es ist ja so, dass viel mehr sendet in unserem täglichen Lebensbereich, als die meisten Menschen wissen.
Zahnbürsten?
Vielleicht wissen die wenigsten Leute, dass ihr Radioapparat, wenn sie Radio empfangen, auch sendet. Weil die heutigen Empfänger, die meisten, die haben einen lokalen Sender und mischen dieses Signal auf ein bestimmtes Zwischenfrequenzsignal herunter. Und dabei entweicht auch immer Störstrahlung. Es wird auch immer unbeabsichtigt gesendet. Mittlerweile darf man ja im FM-Band senden, aber nur mit 50 Nanowatt.
Sind das dann diese kleinen Stöpsel für das Auto? Die Stöpsel da links ran, dann kannst du mit dem Auto radionieren. Sind das diese Teile?
Ja, aber die Sendeleistung beträgt 50 mal 10 hoch minus 9 Watt.
Das sind Nullen an der falschen Stelle, wenn ich den Techniker richtig verstehe.
Deswegen funktioniert das Zeug auch nie.
Diese Geräte, bei bestimmten Elektronikversendern gehen die Reihenweise wieder zurück, weil die Leute einfach sagen, das Ding funktioniert nicht. Selbst auf ganz kurze Entfernungen, selbst wenn es nur 30 Zentimeter sind, kriegt man das mit dem Radio kaum rein und das Rausch. Weil der Rauschabstand gar nicht ausreicht, um ein ordentliches Stereo Signal, was diese Geräte immer dann produzieren, sauber wiedergeben zu können.
Jetzt hast du gerade gesagt, 50 Nanowatt, wie viel haben die dann?
Das hängt von der Betriebsspannung ab. Wenn man bis 15 Volt hochgeht, dann sind das schon so eher 200 Milliwatt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon mal viel mehr.
Das sind sehr viele Größenordnungen.
Jetzt würde ich von dir als Erster, aber auch keiner von den beiden anderen wissen, was glaubst du, was die Faszination dahinter ist, an UKW zu senden? Balmah hat ja erzählt, das Geile am Live-Podcast ist dieser direkte Rückkanal. Und wenn man es digital hat, weiß man auch genau, ich hab jetzt so und so viele Hörer und so was. Aber anscheinend hat dieses UKW-Ding, dieses ins Ungewisse hinaus Blasen, so ein Reiz. Wo liegt dieser Reiz?
Schwer zu sagen. Mich hat immer fasziniert, dass Radiowellen an sich einfach durch den Raum und durch die Zeit bewegen und kein Medium brauchen. Sondern sie brauchen eben nichts, nur Raum. Früher, man redet ja heute noch von dem berühmten Äther, weil man gedacht hat, es müsste irgendeine Art von Substanz, ein Fluidum geben, was diese Wellen benutzen. Aber dann hat man irgendwann festgestellt, zur großen Enttäuschung, sie brauchen einfach nur Raum. Und irgendwie hat mich das halt fasziniert. Schon als Kind.
Ich glaube, das ist vielleicht auch so ein bisschen eine Generationensache.
Aber ich muss noch ganz kurz sagen, dir ist es eigentlich egal, ob dich jemand zuhört.
Ich sende ja nicht illegal, das ist ja illegal.
Aber wenn du es in einem Land tun würdest, wo es nicht illegal wäre, wäre es zu sagen, die Faszination würde dann daran bestehen, deine Information in den Raum zu senden, und es wäre erstmal egal, ob die irgendwo ankommen.
Unter Umständen, ja. Aber wenn natürlich Leute zugehören, wäre es natürlich umso besser.
Ja, ich meine, eigentlich könnte man ja das Argument anführen, dass es viel faszinierender sein müsste, ins Internet zu streamen, weil potenziell die ganze Welt zuhört. Was bei UKW ja nicht so ist. Aber ich glaube, das ist einerseits, also ich bin zumindest durch UKW sozialisiert. Und dann kommt da halt nochmal so eine Sache des zufälligen Einschaltens. Also wir sitzen jetzt hier und blasen das raus. Und es kann sein, dass irgendwo auf der Autobahn jetzt zufällig jemand hier einschaltet, der mit uns nichts zu tun hat und mit dem ganzen Thema nichts zu tun hat. Und man denkt hoch.
Und dann hoffen wir, dass es in unserer Sendung hängen bleibt.
Ja, aber so viel nicht zu Chaosradio kommen. Also ich hab das hier auf der Autobahn, im Stau vor Berlin, in Michendorf, hab ich Chaosradios zum ersten Mal gehört. Das war, weiß ich nicht, eine einstellige Folge damals noch. Und jetzt sitze ich hier.
Wie konnte das passieren?
Das ist halt in diesem ganzen Live-Podcasten eigentlich noch nicht wirklich drin. Also wir weisen jetzt auf unsere Sachen so hin. Vielleicht geht dann jetzt mal jemand hin. Aber das ist halt wirklich faszinierend. Das ist potentiell einfach in diesem Umfeld jetzt hier jeder, der noch so fern als diese Thematik jetzt gerade hier vielleicht reinplatzen kann.
In dem Zusammenhang sollte ich unbedingt noch Tetsuo Kogawa erwähnen. Das ist ein Japaner. Ein Anarchist, der berühmt geworden ist, dadurch, dass er so kleine Bausätze, also es sind nicht mal Bausätze, es sind Bauanleitungen, wie man selber solche Radiosender bauen kann. Nur mit wenigen Komponenten. Und die Platinen stellt man sogar selber her, indem man Platinenmaterial zersägt und dann so kleine Platininseln auf die größere Platine draufklebt. Und es war nicht illegal, das zu tun in Japan lange Zeit. Auch so Garagentoröffner haben zum Beispiel im FM-Rundfunkband gesendet. Und Tetsuo Kogaga hat eine regelrechte Bewegung damit losgetreten. Also es wurde irgendwann mal geschätzt, dass es 3000 solcher kleinen Piratenradio-Stationen gibt, wo teilweise Hausfrauen aus Hochhäusern heraus irgendwie den Block abgedeckt haben. Und dass Leute einfach selber Radio gemacht haben, das ganz spontan gemacht haben. Im Prinzip ist das eine Kunstform. Und eigentlich, das Schöne daran ist, es wird niemand einen Schaden damit zugefügt. So ein kleiner Sender, der stört kaum, zum Beispiel Radio Fritz würde er kaum stören, nur auf ein paar Meter wahrscheinlich. Und das ist irgendwie ein wirklich interessanter Aspekt. Und Tetsuo Kogaga ist in bestimmten Kreisen damit sehr bekannt geworden. Ich finde das eine schöne Sache.
Aber es geht doch auch irgendwie legal. Ich kann mich erinnern, dass ich vor drei Jahren im Sommer mal mit Tim Pötloff einen Podcast gemacht habe. Und da haben wir gleichzeitig bei einer Radioaktion im Prenzlauer Berg, die meiner Ansicht nach völlig legal war, das auch gleich in UKW gemacht. Und du selbst warst ja auch mal irgendwie da. Also da gibt es ja nun auch Möglichkeiten, auch legal ins UKW zu kommen, ohne gleich den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk zu fahren.
Man kann Veranstaltungsfrequenzen beantragen. Also ich habe selber bei verschiedenen Radioprojekten mitgemacht. Herbstradio, Radio-Ref, Juni-Radio und so weiter und so fort. Wo man für einen Monat oder für sechs Wochen eine Frequenz beantragen kann. Aber das kostet dann schon auch immer richtig Geld, also so im fünfstelligen Bereich. Da gab es dann aber irgendwo Fördergelder irgendwie für diese Projekte und die wurden halt gefördert. So einfach ohne weiteres geht es nicht. Aber zum Beispiel auf dem Chaoscamp, kann ich mir erinnern, irgendwie vor einigen Jahren gab es glaube ich einen 10 Watt Sender und der war halt auch völlig legal, weil er eben nur für diese Veranstaltung irgendwie eine Lizenz hatte.
Auf diesem Chaoscamp auch. Da gab es die ganze Zeit, 24 Stunden, ich hätte bald gesagt 24, 7, aber das Camp hat nicht so lange gedauert, also Campradio. Das ist natürlich eine schöne Formel auch, weil man dann gleichzeitig lokal per UKW senden kann und ins Internet streamen kann und anschließend das noch als Podcast anbieten kann. Das heißt, dass man drei Distributionsformen hat.
Diese Sache mit diesen 50 Nanowatt, also das ist etwas, was mich persönlich vollkommen ärgert. Wir haben diese Regelungen nur deshalb, weil Leute für ihre Apple iPods überall auf der Welt diese Geräte, diese Minisender gekauft haben. Die waren zwar illegal, aber die wurden irgendwann im Nachhinein legalisiert, weil man konnte es nicht verbieten. Aber dadurch, dass diese unsägliche Beschränkung wirklich auf dem Dreck unter dem Fingernagel, den man mit einem Mikroskop suchen muss, beschränkt ist, sind die Leute, die diese Geräte kaufen, erstmal frustriert und vollkommen enttäuscht. Und irgendwie fände ich das wunderbar, zum Beispiel wenn jemand seinen Podcast hört und das mit seinem Minisender überträgt, dass das jemand in seinem Wohnblock hören kann, ohne dass er selber den Stream macht. Oder dass man ein Mesh-Netzwerk verwendet, dass man an seinen Router einen USB-Stick einsteckt und damit den Stream abspielt. Wo dann vielleicht sogar noch die Leute irgendwie die Playlist editieren können. Das wären alles wunderbare Sachen. Scheitert halt wieder an irgendwelchen unsäglichen Regelungen, die eigentlich wirklich niemandem nützen.
Ein Punkt, dem jetzt gerade aufgefallen ist, ist, dass das Argument für ein UKW, ist ja sozusagen dieses Reinseppen. Also man sendet das halt und dann kann halt zuhören, wer will. Und auch das ist wieder was, was ist so ein bisschen wie vorhin mit dem Livestream sozusagen. Der Podcast ist ja mal aufgebrochen auch, glaube ich. So habe ich es zumindest lange Zeit erlebt, um Themen abzudecken, die man in einem allgemeinen Radio nicht bringen kann, weil es zu viele Leute ausschließt. Und dann ist doch wieder diese Faszination dahingehend zu sagen, okay, wir möchten aber doch eigentlich irgendwie alle haben. Wie geschaltet ihr denn eure Sendung? Für alle oder für ein bestimmtes Publikum?
Ich weiß gar nicht, woher das kommt. Viele haben ja das gemacht. Es gibt ja viele Tech-Podcasts sozusagen. Gibt es ja ganz viele. Das war für mich so der Anfang. Mittlerweile weicht sich das so ein bisschen auf. Und ich hoffe eigentlich, dass das Podcast-Ding halt, dass Leute, die Podcasts machen, mehr Themen machen für Leute, die einfach mit dieser ganzen Szene erstmal nichts zu tun haben. Das ist primär erstmal eine Audioübertragung. Ein Weg, Audio zu übertragen. Und ich weiß nicht, warum das überhaupt inhaltlich an irgendwas gebunden werden soll und warum das auch überhaupt formatsmäßig überhaupt gebunden sein soll. An jetzt eine Gesprächsrunde oder was auch immer. Man kann ja ganz viele sein. Man kann damit eigentlich alles machen, was man halt eben aufnehmen kann. Und auch schneiden und produzieren kann. Und ich glaube, dass das halt auch ganz noch am Anfang ist, die ganze Podcastgeschichte.
Aber dann wäre die Vermutung trotzdem zu sagen, selbst wenn du über Häkeln, Gärtnerei, Modelleisenbahnen, Kaninchenzuchten-Podcast machst, würde der sich immer eher an ein Fachpublikum der jeweiligen Richtung widmen.
Nee, musst du es ja nicht. Du musst ja nicht sowas machen. Du kannst doch genauso wie im normalen Radio auch Themen behandeln, die jeden interessieren. Oder die zumindest eben nicht nur Fachidioten, in Anführungszeichen, spannend finden. Ich maße mir jetzt an, dass ich keine Zielgruppe habe mit dem, was ich da mache. Also mit den Interviews zum Beispiel. Das sind halt Leute, die sind interessiert an Interviews.
Wenn du jetzt aber dein Publikum beobachtest, findest du, dass es die allgemeine Bevölkerung ist? Oder rekrutiert sich dein Publikum schon aus dieser Internet-affinen Podcast-Hörmolte?
Das rekrutiert sich schon hauptsächlich daraus. Allerdings kriege ich auch eben das Feedback genau, dass das angenehm ist, dass sich das halt nur unterscheidet und sich nicht auf sich selbst bezieht. Also das merke ich schon.
Also man erreicht dann schon noch andere Kreise. Also wie gesagt bei der Liedkultur, das ist natürlich auch ein Podcast, der sich schon irgendwie an diese Internet-Nerd-Gemeinde wendet. Aber wenn dann so Themen kommen, also ich habe einen gemacht über Anime, da kommen natürlich dann die Leute auch, die sich für Anime interessieren und die sonst vielleicht nicht so Podcasts hören. Oder ich habe beim Clavautercast mal was gemacht über das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen. Und das ist unheimlich oft gespiegelt worden. Also einmal haben das andere übernommen auf ihre Seite. Dann haben das einige von den freien Radios auch in ihr Programm eingebaut. Und dadurch hat das eine unheimliche Reichweite bekommen. Und das hören dann eben auch Leute, die vielleicht sonst gar keine Nerds sind.
Aber wenn ihr die Sendung macht, gebt ihr euch dann Mühe, dass ihr denkt, wenn jetzt jemand das zu sagen hört, weil sie sich für das Thema interessiert, dann will ich das auch reingeholt. Also bereitet ihr eine einzelne Sendung vor?
Ja, sicher. Also ich denke, das machen wir alle. Und ich mache auch immer Shownotes, damit man nochmal nachgucken kann, wenn man irgendwas nicht verstanden hat. Weil natürlich nicht alles erklärt wird, wenn sich Leute unterhalten. Erklären sie ja nicht. Wir haben jetzt vorhin auch das Wort Mesh erwähnt. Das kennen ja vielleicht die Leute nicht. Dann kann man in die Shownotes da einen Link reinmachen, auf die Wikipedia am besten, weil man da weiß, das bleibt dann meistens erhalten. Man hat auch immer gerne mal was gelöscht. Aber weniger als jetzt irgendeinen Link. Und dann kann man das nachgucken. Also ich denke, das ist schon eine Möglichkeit.
Also man kann einfach alles machen, was man ansonsten eben auch machen kann im Radio. Die Frage ist halt, ob man die Zeit hat und das Geld. Und ich glaube, das ist so die Frage. Geld inwiefern? Na ja, wenn du viel Zeit investierst in irgendwas, dann musst du ja auch irgendwann damit vielleicht mal was verdienen, weil du sonst irgendwann nichts mehr zu essen hast. Sozusagen ganz einfach ausgedrückt. Ja, musst nicht. Jede Situation ist anders. Aber das ist natürlich so eine Sache. Wenn du das jetzt ständig machen willst, jeden Tag, eine Sendung machen willst, es gibt ja so Beispiele auch, vor allen Dingen in den USA, dann ist es natürlich schon eine Frage, wie kannst du dir das leisten?
Jetzt hatten wir es ja vorhin schon gesagt, die Frage, ob ich damit vorstellen könnte, Geld zu verdienen, das wäre okay anscheinend. Wie viel würdet ihr in den Kauf nehmen an Einbußen, um weiter podcasten zu können, wenn das nicht geht? Ist das schon so eine Sache für euch geworden, wo ihr denkt, Podcast, ich will das jetzt unbedingt machen, oder ist das auch so etwas, wo ihr leichten Herzen sagen würdet, okay, das ist mir jetzt ein bisschen zu aufwendig, ich kann mir das gerade nicht leisten? Ist das so eine Herzblutsache?
Ja schon, das hätte ich am Anfang ja auch nicht gedacht, aber nach inzwischen 77 Podcasts, oder mehr sogar. Also noch nicht so viel wie du vielleicht.
Ich glaube sogar mehr ehrlich gesagt.
Also das möchte ich jetzt nicht missen. Also das ist eigentlich eine schöne Sache. Also dann habe ich auch das Bedürfnis, wenn ich länger keinen Podcast aufgenommen habe, denke ich immer, jetzt muss ich mal wieder. Das ist schon fast zwanghaft.
Die sogenannte Rotlichtzucht.
Das sollte jetzt auch nicht rüber kommen, dass ich das für Geld machen will. Sondern das sollte nur klar machen, dass man natürlich, wenn man viel Zeit für Produktionen reinsteckt, dass das halt irgendwann gemacht werden muss und man ja auch irgendwie noch Geld verdienen muss.
Würdest du es weitermachen, wenn das Entbehrungen bedeutet?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also es ist eine Leidenschaft, das auf jeden Fall. Das ist ja eben großartig. Man kann auf einmal was tun, was sonst nur Leute wie du da hinter dem Pult machen können. Ja, da ist so ein bisschen so ein Elfenbeinturm aufgebrochen, wie es das Internet mit vielen Sachen macht.
Medien selber machen.
Genau, und das ist glaube ich so die Sache, die ist jetzt entstanden. Und ich glaube bei vielen Sachen, bei Blogs, bei Podcasts, kommt dann auch irgendwann der Moment, wo man merkt, dass es eine Schwemme an Sachen gibt und dann muss man irgendwie Qualität bringen. Und das finde ich halt ziemlich wichtig. Die Möglichkeiten hat man halt auch inhaltlich wirklich bei Podcasts.
Das ist eine spannende Frage, dass sich ja irgendwann so ein gewisses Niveau herausbildet. Also irgendwie so die guten Podcaster investieren halt irgendwie drei- bis vierstellige Beträge in ihr Equipment, machen Sendungsvorbereitungen, haben dann auch die bekannteren Leute am Start, weil die einfach selber auch bekannt sind. Dürfen die Kleinen dann irgendwie nicht mehr podcasten? Also glaubt ihr, dass dann sozusagen so eine Qualitätsverschiebung so, dass man so dann die Leute belächelt, die es einfach aus Hobby machen?
Also wenn ich was antworten darf, also die Qualität setzt sich da glaube ich durch. Also das ist überhaupt, es gibt zwar so Platzhirsch-Tendenzen glaube ich schon beim Podcasting, auch in Deutschland, aber da ist glaube ich noch sehr viel Platz. Und man beobachtet auch, wenn Leute was Ungewöhnliches mal machen, was ausprobieren, dass da schon genug Hörerschaft noch da ist.
Das Schöne ist doch, dass es jeder machen darf, ob man damit erfolgreich ist oder nicht, das steht auf einem anderen Plan. Was ist Erfolg? Wenn man eine Reichweite hat, würde ich sagen. Also ich selber mache einen Podcast, ich präsentiere jetzt meinen eigenen, er heißt Dogmatic-Podcast.info und ich habe nur eine ganz geringe Reichweite, weil meine Botschaft ist nicht sehr populär.
Hätte ich jetzt bei dem Namen gar nicht gedacht. Aber was heißt nicht populär? Kannst du ungefähr abschätzen, wie viele Downloads, Hörer du hast?
Das sind wahrscheinlich in der Größenordnung vielleicht von 50 Leuten, die sich so einen Podcast von mir runtergeladen haben.
Aber das zu sagen, ist dir genug?
Das ist schön, wenn es mehr werden. Aber ich verstehe schon, dass der Inhalt nicht so leicht viral wird und populär wird.
Aber 50 Leute ist doch auch schon was. Wenn du pro Episode 50 Leute erreichst, ist das doch eigentlich viel. Es gibt Leute, die haben Bücher geschrieben und veröffentlicht, die vielleicht nicht mal von 10 Leuten gelesen worden sind.
Das ist eine spannende Frage, ob wir bei Podcasts tatsächlich sagen, wenn diese Lust daran, dass es viele Leute hören, die könnte ja möglicherweise zu einer Boulevardisierung der Podcast-Szene führen. Wir kommen es gerade so vor, als ob es zumindest eine Zukunftsperspektive gibt, die nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich ist, wo Podcasts das selbe machen. Durchmachen wir es wie die klassischen Massenmedien, also experimentell, dann für jedermann verfügbar, also konsumierbar. Und dann irgendwann werden sich die Dinge durchsetzen, die leicht zu konsumieren sind, weil die so schön...
Das Schöne ist doch, früher war das so, die Deutungshoheit lag bei wenigen Leuten oder bei Staaten, die die Medien machen konnten. Eine öffentliche Meinung zu beeinflussen oder überhaupt Informationen in der Öffentlichkeit zu servieren, denen zugänglich zu machen oder sie ihnen aufzuoktruieren. Das war damit verbunden, dass man Geld hatte für eine Druckerpresse, Vertriebssystem, die Hoheit ausüben konnte über Senderechte. Ich meine, warum gab es denn dieses Gesetz von 1937 aus der Nazi-Zeit, wo dann während des Zweiten Weltkriegs Leute mit dem Tode bestraft wurden für das Betreiben einer Sendeanlage oder auch nur den Besitz von Teilen davon. Es ging darum, wer hat die Deutungshoheit. Und das Schöne heutzutage ist, dass jeder kann da mitmischen. Die Frage ist natürlich, wie erfolgreich wird es populär, werden die Botschaften ausgenommen, wie serviert man das, wie professionalisiert man das. Und da haben wir hier natürlich auch Leute, die es sehr erfolgreich machen.
Indeed. Wir haben jetzt noch einen Anrufer, den wir kurz vor dem Fritz-Info noch unterbringen wollen. Das ist Marvin. Hallo Marvin. Hallo. Du, ich werde nicht ganz schlau, die wunderbare Redakteurin schrieb rein, du podcastest nicht, aber beschäftigst dich mit Livestreams. Erkläre er sich.
Und zwar ist mir das Eingefahrene von fast ein Jahr war das. Da habe ich dann auch so angefangen, Podcasts zu hören. Und fand mit der Möglichkeit, live zu hören, sehr verlockend. Und dann habe ich mal geguckt, was man denn da braucht, um auch selber ein Livestream zu machen. Und bin dann unter anderem auch auf eine relativ neue Möglichkeit gestoßen, die es da gibt. Das ist ja das sogenannte HTCP Livestreaming. Es wurde von Apple entwickelt. Und das fand ich sehr interessant, weil man braucht halt nur einen eigenen Web-Server, wo man dann halt ganz normal Dateien drauf platzieren kann, um einen Stream zu erstellen.
Ich verstehe nicht genau den Unterschied zu dem Sagen zu anderem Streaming.
Also man braucht halt keinen speziellen Streaming-Server mehr, sondern halt einen ganz normalen HTCP-Server wie den Apache oder so, den man sich bei den meisten Hostern sehr billig klicken kann. Und dann muss man halt dann nur die einzelnen Audio-Segmente raufladen, also die Audio-Sachen, die man veröffentlichen möchte. Dazu braucht man halt auch eine entsprechende Software.
Ok, aber bevor ich es richtig verstehe, du lädst sozusagen fertige Audiodateien da hoch.
Genau.
Aber dann ist es ja kein Livestream mehr.
Doch, doch, das ist schon, weil es gibt halt eine Software dafür, die lädt dann, also das ist natürlich nicht ganz live, aber so zehn Sekunden Latenz ungefähr. Weil die lädt halt einzelne kurze, sehr kurze Audiodegmente hoch immer.
Und womit kann man das hören? Braucht man dann irgendwie spezielle Software für oder?
Ja, zurzeit kann man das eigentlich so fast nur mit Apple-Geräten hören. Das ist ja eine sehr blöde Begrenzung. Aber bald dann auch mit VLC zum Beispiel und so. Das ist halt wie gesagt noch sehr neu.
Okay, aber möglicherweise geht der Weg dorthin, dass man sagen, mit noch weniger Aufwand noch mehr Livestream kann. Und Marvin hat es schon mal ausprobiert. Vielen Dank für deinen Anruf und viel Spaß beim HTTP-Livestream. Wir werden gleich hier noch für die wesentlichste, wichtigste und überhaupteste Podcasterfrage ever klären. Und das ist, wie lange ist ein guter Podcast?
Zwei Sprechstunden.
Eine halbe Stunde haben wir noch hier im Chaosradio im Blue Moon, wo es heute um Podcasten geht, wo wir versuchen zu erklären, ob das wirklich jeder machen kann. Und die Antwort lautet bis jetzt Ja, weil die Technik ist relativ erschwinglich. Man muss ein Thema haben und möglicherweise auch ein Gast. Das kann eine ganz gute Idee sein. Und apropos, ich begrüße noch mal Nikolas Simak, den Podcaster. Guten Tag. Maha und Elektra vom Chaos Computer Club. Und jetzt haben wir schon die technischen Voraussetzungen besprochen und die Inhaltlichen und auch wie man das mit dem Publikum macht und wie man livestreamt. Die Frage, die sie jetzt noch stellt, ist, wie lange darf denn so ein Podcast sein? Also wenn man sich sozusagen anguckt, was so erfolgreich ist, dann könnte man den Eindruck gewinnen, je länger, desto besser. Vier Stunden, sechs Stunden, wer bietet mehr? Was macht ihr?
Ja, also ich finde schon, dass man beim Podcast die Chance hat, auch länger was zu machen. Das ist einfach eine ganz große Möglichkeit und das ist eben auch der Unterschied zum klassischen Radio, was ja immer sehr kurze Formate hat. Also wenn ein Thema richtig spannend ist und man gute Gesprächspartner hat, finde ich es auch gut, wenn das ein bisschen länger dauert. Also ich bin wirklich der Meinung, dass 3- bis 4-stündige Podcasts auch möglich sind, denn die Leute müssen das ja nicht am Stück hören. Also ich finde das gut, aber es gibt natürlich andere Geschmäcker. Ich glaube, Niklas hat es...
Du meinst, weil ich jetzt so gelacht habe? Nein, das hängt halt vom Format ab, glaube ich. Also das ist wie bei den anderen Medien auch. Es ist erstmal grundsätzlich toll, dass man die Zeit hat. Das ist erstmal spannend. Andererseits finde ich, also bei mir geht es gerade in die Tendenz, dass ich merke, ein bisschen strukturieren, ein bisschen knapper machen kann auch ganz schön sein. Aber das ist eben formatsabhängig. Ich glaube, man kann jetzt nicht allgemein sagen, das ist die richtige Länge für einen Podcast. Das ist irgendwie schwierig. Eine Gesprächsrunde, wenn man Zeit hat, ist toll. Das ist halt das Gute am Podcast.
Ja, man hat eben Zeit, wenn man nicht so Zeitdruck hat, dass man nach einer bestimmten Zeit fertig sein muss. Das ist eben das Gute. Das ist halt eine unheimliche Freiheit. Im Radio kommt dann der nächste Slot. Und hier kann man einfach mal drauf losreden.
Es gibt vielleicht eine Art von Format, was besonders gut bei vielen Leuten ankommt. Aber die Freiheit hat man, das zu machen, wie man möchte.
Ja, und ich glaube, es gibt schon Gründe dafür, auch mal zu kürzen oder sich im Vorhinein vielleicht Gedanken darüber zu machen, wie lange muss jetzt ein bestimmter Teil dieses Gesprächs vielleicht ungefähr einnehmen, um alles zu beleuchten. Und ja, also so komplett unvorbereitet reinzugehen, ist jetzt nicht so mein Ding. Und das würde auch bedeuten, dass man ausufert. Und ich weiß nicht, also ich bin schon für so einen Spannungsbogen, vielleicht sagen wir es mal so, das finde ich notwendig.
Irgendwann ist auch die Aufmerksamkeit einfach nicht mehr da.
Ja, das wollte ich gerade sagen, also als Macher, bei mir ist es sowohl als Macher als auch als Hörer, finde ich, ist eine Stunde so ein schöner Rahmen. Ich habe kaum etwas selber gehört oder auch gemacht, wo ich dachte, länger als eine Stunde muss man das jetzt machen, also als Podcast.
Aber woran machst du das fest, die Stunde? Das ist jetzt für dein spezielles Format, oder?
Nö, das ist tatsächlich einfach ein Gefühl. Also ich kann nach einer Stunde nicht mehr zuhören, da habe ich die Nase voll.
Deswegen nicht aufmerksamkeitsspannend, sozusagen.
Möglicherweise ist es nur das. Aber ihr sagt ja gerade sozusagen, die Länge kann gehen. Es gibt jetzt auch das Wort vom Laberpodcast, das kommt ja nicht von ungefähr. Wenn ihr Podcasts hört, wie lange darf es denn da sein?
Das ist halt bei mir persönlich, hat sich das eben verändert. Also früher fand ich dieses grundsätzliche Argument, dass es nicht lang genug sein kann, was man ja oft hört beim Podcasting, hat für mich auch total gestimmt. Und mittlerweile bewege ich mich ein bisschen davon weg, weil ich denke, ja, jetzt kommt doch mal zu Potter so ein bisschen. Also das kann jeder machen, wie er will. Es gibt auch Leute, die genau andersrum das sehen. Ich glaube, du siehst es anders.
Ja, ich sehe es wirklich anders.
Du siehst es vielleicht auch von der Macht. Es ist halt auch mal die Frage, macht man es für sich oder macht man es für die Hörer? Da muss man wahrscheinlich eine gute Balance finden.
Okay, ich wollte gerade sagen, ich mach es für mich. Also ich muss natürlich schon Spaß dabei haben. Aber ich denke auch als Hörer. Ich habe auch Podcasts gehört, die waren so spannend, dass ich gar nicht gemerkt habe, wie viel Zeit vergangen ist. Und dann war ich ja froh, dass es so lange gedauert hat. Und wenn es halt nicht gut ist, dann kann ich ja abschalten. Aber ich habe auch die Freiheit, jederzeit abzuschalten. Ich kann sagen, das will ich jetzt nicht mehr hören, ich schalte ab oder ich schlafe ein.
In dem Moment war es ja eine unbefriedigende Sendung. Also genau. Aber klar.
Und als Podcastmacher kann ich natürlich nicht abschalten, aber dann merke ich...
Das ist ja auch.
Man hatte den Eindruck, manche Leute machen...
Aber das ist da ja auch so. Manchmal ist es halt so spannend. Ich habe mal einen Podcast mit Philipp Banzo gemacht bei Küchenradio. Das war so spannend. Wir haben es selber irgendwie nicht so richtig gemerkt. Bei Philipp kann man erst mal ganz spät anfangen, weil er erst sein Kind ins Bett bringen muss und so. Dann haben wir irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, haben wir noch Vorgespräch geführt, haben wir irgendwie um halb elf angefangen. Und als wir fertig waren, konnte ich die erste U-Bahn wieder nehmen. Also das kann schon ausufern, aber das war dann einfach so spannend, dass wir das gar nicht gemerkt haben. Das ist dann wie so ein Raum-Zeit-Paradox, so ein Wurmloch. Dann fährt plötzlich die U-Bahn wieder.
Da waren auch Drohungen im Spiel.
Ich glaube, das kann man auch genauso wenig beantworten, wie man jetzt sagen kann, das ist die beste Länge für einen Blogartikel. Das hängt halt am Inhalt und an dem, was man machen will. Ich finde Laber-Podcasts total toll, also ich mache ja selber einen, muss ich ja sagen. Das hängt halt am Format. Die Frage kann man glaube ich nicht beantworten.
Wenn es jemand gelingt, mich 4 Stunden an den Lautsprecher zu fesseln, ist das gut, aber das kann man natürlich nicht ständig hören.
Das ist ja was, was ich noch nie verstanden habe, weil da geht für mich jegliche Dramaturgie im Gespräch auch verloren.
Das ist unterschiedlich. Es gibt Podcasts, die kann ich nicht mit mehrfacher Geschwindigkeit hören. Mehrfach sowieso nicht, also anderthalbfach. Also ich will jetzt auch keine Namen nennen, oder ich kann schon Namen nennen. Podcasts mit Fefe und Frank sind halt mit anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit nicht erträglich. Das geht halt nicht. Das liegt aber an dieser besonderen Art der Dramaturgie, auch der Kommunikation. Und andere wiederum kann ich, zum Beispiel höre ich sehr viel, HR2 der Tag und HR2 der Tag. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass das ein schlechter Podcast ist, aber das ist einfach ein Podcast, den kann man in doppelter Geschwindigkeit oder in anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit Probleme haben.
Was ist das? Also was ist das für Format? Was passiert da?
Na das ist so eine, ja das ist eigentlich Kulturradio mit Info. Also die machen halt immer ein Thema, auf ein politisches Thema jeden Tag, was gerade aktuell ist, sagen wir mal Bankenkrise und so. Und machen das so ein bisschen ja kulturell verbrennt, also wie Vögelton. Da gibt es also verschiedene Interviewbeiträge und dann wird auch mal ein Text vorgetragen zwischendurch. Da gibt es halt immer auch noch so ein bisschen was Literarisches. Und das ist halt, das plätschert halt so, dass man das ruhig mit anderthalbfacher Geschwindigkeit hören kann. Und dann ist es halt ganz schnell vorbei. Dann ist es halt in 25 Minuten vorbei.
Da würde ich ja verrückt werden. Was plant ihr als nächstes für das Podcasten?
Naja, wie gesagt, also Liedkultur, also um es nochmal zu sagen, 1337kultur schreibt man das, .de. Da mache ich jetzt am Sonntag was über ja so ein bisschen innegeile Kunst im öffentlichen Raum. Deshalb darf ich da auch nicht zu viel verraten, wo ich da spreche und so.
Denk sie!
Kann man auch im Stream hören. Das ist so ein Thema, was ich seit langem machen wollte. Also vor allen Dingen auch so diese im Grunde, das ist jetzt nicht direkt ein Hip Hopper, aber so diese Hip Hop Sache, Graffiti und so. Das wollte ich eigentlich angehen. Da muss man halt den richtigen Gesprächspartner finden. Jetzt habe ich einen Konzept Künstler. Das ist also nicht wirklich Hip Hop, also die Richtung. Dann, wie gesagt, Motorradfahren würde ich gerne machen. Da fehlt mir der Gesprächspartner. Dann würde ich auch nochmal Jugendbücher machen. Da fehlt noch der Gesprächspartner. Ich habe da verschiedene Ideen im Kulturbereich, für die ich noch Gesprächspartner suche. Aber da geht irgendwie alles beim Kulturbereich. Das steht vor allen Dingen an.
Ich muss ja ganz ehrlich gestehen, dass meine Frage nicht darauf hinausliegt, die Programmsache für die nächsten drei Wochen zu machen, sondern ob ihr an der Art und Weise, wie ihr podcastet, noch was noch was... Hörertalk zum Beispiel ist so ein Thema. Meint ihr, so etwas wird auch im Podcast kommen?
Das gibt es ja schon. Das macht ja dein Kollege Holger. Das funktioniert auf jeden Fall. Er hat jede Woche mehrere Leute an seinem Skype hängen. Er rekrutiert natürlich direkt aus seiner Hörerschaft, aber das ist ja auch logisch.
Bei Holgi ist es ja so, der hat ja schon sein großes Publikum. Jetzt nimmt er einfach in diesen neuen Raum mit. Aber glaubt ihr generell, dass das Format Hörertalk auch im Podcast funktionieren wird? Oder kommen wird?
Also ich denke, dass das Format, das geht schon. Also ich denke, das ist möglich. Da gibt es schon viele Beispiele. Und warum nicht? Also ich glaube ja sowieso, dass es so eine Annäherung geben wird. Man sieht es ja schon, Podcasts, also jetzt gibt es viele Leute, die streamen ihren Podcasts auch. Da haben wir schon eine Annäherung als Radio mit HL2 der Tag und vielen anderen Beispielen. Das gesamte öffentlich-rechtliche Programm scheint schon verpodcastet zu sein, mehr oder weniger. Und so gibt es da eine Annäherung. Und Talkradio und so gehört natürlich auch dazu.
Man sollte vielleicht auch nochmal iTunes erwähnen mit seinem Verzeichnis, was da nämlich eine ganz spannende Sache ist, was ja für den Podcaster vor allen Dingen irgendwie eine skurrile Situation ist, wenn man sich dann, da sind dann diese Charts, und dann sieht man dann, ja dann ist es eine Produktion von Radio 1 dann und danach kommst du dann, Maha, und dann kommt wieder, also da sieht man diese Vermischung extrem. Und das ist ja auch glaube ich ein Ort, wo viele Leute auch suchen nach neuen Dingen, nach neuen Podcasts. Und das ist halt eine ganz großartige Auflösung dieser hierarchischen Strukturen, die man da eigentlich hatte, was ich total spannend finde.
Aber apropos hierarchische Struktur, ist es ja tatsächlich so, dass dieses iTunes, also Apple quasi, da so ein riesen Daumen drauf hat, also quasi eine Monopolbildung, gibt es irgendwelche anderen Podcasts, Verzeichnisse oder irgendwas, wie das kommuniziert wird?
Das ist ja kein Monopol. Die haben halt als erstes die Idee gehabt, das mal vernünftig irgendwo einzubauen. Das kann ja jeder andere auch tun. Also das steht ja, anderen Betriebssystem entwickeln.
Nein, nicht Monopol im Sinne von, dass sie das technisch abschließen, aber das ist einfach die einzigen, in meiner Wahrnehmung zumindest, wo das überhaupt irgendwie passiert. Warum gibt es das nicht woanders?
Also eigentlich, das haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt, wenn man den Leuten sagt, wie macht man Podcasts. Also ist ja die Frage, wie wird das verteilt? Und was man halt braucht, ist halt irgendeine Blogsoftware, sagen wir WordPress und ein Podcastplugin. Und dann gibt es ein RSS-Feed und so. Und dann brauchen die Leute auch keine iTunes. Dann können sie einfach auf die Seite gehen und diesen Feed abonnieren. Und damit funktioniert das schon.
Ja klar, also das war jetzt auch nicht gemeint, dass sie es brauchen zum Hören. Das ist ja klar. Das ist halt ein Ort, wo man die gut finden kann. Und ich meine, es gibt Google. Und dann gibt es, ich meine klar, es gibt ein paar Seiten, ein paar Verzeichnisse schon. Also Podcast.de und solche Sachen, die sind mehr oder weniger schön zu benutzen. Und auch, naja, es ist halt ein bisschen schwierig. Aber es gibt ja auch zum Beispiel, gerade auf dem iPhone und auch auf den anderen Smartphones, glaube ich, sogenannte Podcatcher. Also eben Programme, die erst mal Podcasts abspielen. Und dann eben auch interne Suchsysteme haben. Und da kann man dann eben auch Sachen finden. Also man kann nach Namen suchen, man kann sich Sachen vorstellen lassen. Also Top 25 gibt es da und solche Geschichten. Also ja, es gibt da schon eine Menge Möglichkeiten, was zu finden.
Und was man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen sollte, weil du sagst, was sind so die Perspektiven? Ich finde ja, es sollte da viel mehr Crossover und Remixing und Vermission geben. Also ich hatte ja schon mal diese Sache mit dem Grundeinkommen, die dann auch in verschiedenen freien Radios gelaufen ist. Aber das sollte eigentlich so zur Regel werden, dass sich da alle austauschen und dass eben das eine auch noch woanders läuft. Und dass beim Streaming, wenn gerade bei so einem Streaming-Server nichts läuft, dass man vielleicht irgendwelche Sachen nochmal wiederholen kann und so. Also dass es da einfach mehr Vermischung gibt.
Das ist ja was, worauf ich noch warte, zu sagen, dass es demnächst mal so ein Streaming-Dienst, wo Podcasts live gestreamt werden, anfängt, einfach 24 Stunden ein Signal zu bieten. Also erstmal egal was das ist, aber ob das wirklich passieren wird. Und dann ist man wieder beim Radio, das finde ich schon sehr spannend.
Und ich denke vielleicht kann man irgendwann auch mal das UKW übernehmen. Viele Sender gehen in den digitalen Bereich, dann wird das UKW frei. Und da es diese Radios immer geben wird, zur Notbastelsicherheit, kann man doch da irgendwie auch noch UKW. Also da muss natürlich gesetzlich was geregelt werden, aber wenn da kein Bedarf mehr ist für so viele Frequenzen, da wird sich das automatisch ergeben.
Das UKW ist tot, lang lebe das UKW quasi? Aber der hat ja gar keinen Rückkanal mehr, der so wichtig war. Haben wir noch was vergessen zu Podcasts?
Da kann man sehr viel darüber erzählen. Außerdem, der Rückkanal ist ja nicht weg. Durch das Netz hat man ja nach wie vor immer noch einen Rückkanal. Das ist ja in diese Verknüpfung. Internet plus Radio. Und das wird dann das Neue.
Na ja, bei einem Livestream weißt du, wie viele Leute deinen Stream gerade hören. Beim Podcast weißt du, wie viele Leute den heruntergeladen haben. Aber hier im Radio weiß man ja nicht. Da muss man irgendwie höhere Umfragen machen. Muss man schauen. Das ist ja immer auch eine Schwierigkeit hier für jeden Sender.
Ja, gerade um diese Zeit weiß man eigentlich nicht so genau aus.
Genau. Aber wenn man da einen Rückkanal hat, dann sieht man ja, reagieren die Leute, reagieren sie nicht. Wie viele Flatter...
Aber du kannst nicht beziffern, wie viele von den Leuten geben dir ein Feedback und wie viele Leute hören einfach nur zu.
So, weil das ja auch die letzte Chaosradio-Sendung im Jahr ist, möchte ich gleich noch mal zu einem kleinen anderen Thema kommen, aber zuvor noch sagen, Abklus, Plädoyer für, ich sitze zu Hause und überlege mir, ob ich jetzt irgendwie selber Audio produzieren soll oder nicht. Herr Seemark.
Um Gottes Willen. Was soll ich denn jetzt... Was soll ich zitieren?
Meinst du mehr Leute, so ein Podcast?
Ja, also grundsätzlich ja bitte, weil das ist in der Entwicklung sozusagen diese ganze Geschichte und man soll sich da nicht scheuen. Und vielleicht auch einfach nicht versuchen, das, was es schon gibt, nochmal nachzumachen. Ich glaube, das wäre jetzt mal so ein Ratschlag. Das kann man natürlich machen und man kommt auch dadurch erstmal auf Ideen. Also meine Sachen haben sich auch erst verändert, nachdem ich angefangen hatte. Aber sich einfach mal trauen. Und ja, das ist einfach mal zu versuchen. Und sich vor allen Dingen vorher überlegen, was man machen will. Das ist, glaube ich, jetzt heutzutage mal angebracht, dass man sagt, warum willst du denn podcasten?
Ja, genau, das würde ich auch sagen. Also es wäre wirklich sehr schön. Ich meine, das ist ja das, warum wir hier sitzen eigentlich auch. Also jeder soll eben der Sender, zum Sender werden. Also es soll wirklich jeder nach Möglichkeit podcasten. Gut, das wird nicht jeder tun. Aber wenn sich die Zahl der Podcaster so ein bisschen erhöhen würde, ist das, glaube ich, wirklich ein Beitrag für eine bessere Welt, würde ich sagen. Also von daher unbedingt. Also alle Leute sollten es mal ausprobieren.
Sendungsbewusstsein bekommt eine ganz neue Bedeutung und wird was Positives, nachdem es jahrelang ein bisschen anders besetzt war. Elektra, ich vermute, wir würden uns da in dasselbe Horn stoßen.
Ja, mein Podcast heißt Dogmatic Podcast, weil ich daran gedacht habe, unter anderem auch, es gibt ja diese Dogma-Reihe. Man braucht nicht, um einen Film zu drehen, immer das teuerste Equipment. Man muss nicht alle Einstellungen irgendwie von der Schiene ausdrehen und einen technischen Totschlag betreiben. Im Prinzip reicht ein externes Mikrofon und ein Computer. Und dann kann man im Prinzip loslegen. Ich weiß nicht, da seid ihr vielleicht anderer Meinung, weil ihr habt einen höheren Professionalitätsanspruch. Aber wenn jemand brilliante Ideen hat und brilliante Situationen schafft und ihr aufzeichnet, gut, irgendwann will man dann eine fantastische Qualität haben, vielleicht. Aber das muss ja nicht unbedingt sein. Die Dogma-Filme waren auch sehr beliebt, obwohl sie nicht mit dem hohen technischen Standard geglänzt haben.
Das kann ja auch einen ganz eigenen Charme haben eben.
Also ich glaube, dass die Professionalisierung, die im Podcastbereich in Deutschland irgendwie anzutreffen ist, vor allen Dingen auch der eine Gründe liegt, dass es viele Leute einfach total großartig finden, neues Equipment zu kaufen.
Ja, das sieht man auch. Dass es sehr viele Podcasts gibt, in denen sich Leute wieder über Equipment unterhalten. Gell, Markus?
Dazu möchte ich jetzt an dieser Stelle nichts sagen.
Und vielleicht möchte ich noch hinzufügen, da ich viel an Entwicklungsteilen unterwegs bin, ich hab das auch schon angeschnitten, aber es gibt viele Leute, die sind mit Internetbreitband nicht so wirklich gesegnet. Und die meisten Leute haben aber diese Leute nicht im Auge. Und vielleicht sollte man immer noch, also ich begrüße das, wenn Leute ihre Formate auch mit niedriger Qualität und entsprechend niedriger Bandbreite anbieten, damit ich die schneller runterladen und auch tatsächlich hören kann, auch wenn ich weniger Bandbreite hab. Ich denke mal, das sollte man vielleicht nicht aus den Augen verlieren.
Was ist denn so deine Detailgröße, wo du sagst, okay, das ist noch machbar?
Also ich hab für mich die Sachen runtergerechnet, ich hab das vorher erwähnt, 20 Kilobit OQaubis. Und damit es dann nicht nach Artefakten klingt, hab ich die Audiobandbreite auf 16 Kilohertz begrenzt und es ist mono.
Genau, aber was ich meine zu sagen, also das Audioverhältnis irgendwo hinstelle, wie groß darf das sein, damit es sozusagen keine Probleme macht? 5 Megabyte, 10?
Na, wenn es eine tolle Sendung ist und die ist zwei Stunden lang, dann ist sie etwa 15 Megabyte groß.
Das kann man also machen. So, also ich fasse mal zusammen, geht hin und sendet. So wurde das hier quasi in zwei Stunden genau erklärt. Ihr könnt euch das übrigens auch noch mal als Podcast anhören. Das gibt es im nächsten Mal auf fritzee.de und dann auch auf chaosradio.de. Der Maha hat im Vorgang zu dieser Sendung gesagt, er könne nicht nur etwas zu Podcasts sagen, sondern auch zu einer seltsamen Veranstaltung, die um die Jahreswende manchmal hier in Bedien stattfindet.
Manchmal, also zur Zeit auch immer regelmäßig. Das kann sich ja schnell ändern. Es geht um den Chaos Communication Congress, der halt immer nach Weihnachten direkt stattfindet, also vom 27. Dezember bis zum 30. Dezember. Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum das Chaosradio entfällt im Dezember, weil da diese Sonderveranstaltung ist. Die ist natürlich sehr voll, ganz schwierig an Tickets dran zu kommen. Deshalb werde ich jetzt nicht dafür werben und machen, dahin zu fahren. Aber, und jetzt sind wir wieder eigentlich beim Thema Podcasting und Streaming, also es wird natürlich live gestreamt von da und die Vorträge werden auch aufgezeichnet. Die gibt es dann nachher auch über BitTorrent und andere Möglichkeiten zum Download. Und da gibt es also viele interessante Sachen. Ist natürlich klar, in diesem Jahr, wo so viel passiert ist mit Staatstreuianer und ähnlichen Dingen, sind natürlich die Themen auch schon irgendwie gesetzt, wieder behandelt werden.
Gibt es da, sagen wir ab, von den offensichtlichen Verdächtigen wie dem Staatstreuianer, der wahrscheinlich ein, zwei, dreimal durch den Saal gekarrt wird, schon andere Vorträge, von denen du weißt?
Ja, also es gibt wieder die üblichen Verdächtigen. Es gibt wieder was zu GSM, weil da ja auch viel gelaufen ist dieses Jahr auf dem Camp. Es wurde ja sogar eine GSM-Basisstation dort fortentwickelt. Und das wird natürlich jetzt fortgesetzt, also zu GSM-Zumenge geben. Also vor allen Dingen Sicherheit in der Telefonie plus wie hacke ich das Smartphone. Also da kann man ein paar schöne Sachen erwarten. Das ist natürlich ganz klar. Ich werde natürlich wieder was über Sprache erzählen. Das ist natürlich klar. Und ich glaube, das Programm ist diesmal ziemlich bunt. Weil einfach so viel los war. Man hat irgendwie das Gefühl, dass in diesem Jahr mehr passiert ist als sonst.
Die Zusammenfassung gibt es dort. Gibt es schon ein Motto?
Oh, da ist noch eine Riesendiskussion.
Ich ziehe die Frage zurück. Wie hieß es in den letzten Jahren? Dragon's Everywhere oder Peace Missions? Gibt es sowas auch wieder?
Das wird es wieder geben. Und deshalb kann auch jeder teilnehmen. Weil es wieder dezentral diesen Kongress gibt. An verschiedenen Orten. Das wiki ist noch nicht am Start. Dann haben wir sehr spät mit den Kongressvorbereitungen angefangen. Aber es wird das alles geben.
Dann ist die letzte Frage, die mich zum Kongress erstellen kann. Wird das WLAN funktionieren dieses Jahr?
Du bist echt gemein. Das letzte Frage.
Wenn du ein Kabel mitbringst, funktioniert es.
Das WLAN-Kabel, das ist natürlich diesmal mitgebracht. Das wird schon irgendwie gehen. Da bin ich eigentlich zuversichtlich.
Dann sehen wir uns alle, wenn ihr mögt, auf dem Kongress. Dann gibt es nächstes Jahr im Januar vielleicht wieder ein Chaosradio. Gibt es euch schon ein Thema?
Wir können gerne noch einen Podcast machen.
Wir können ja unendlich abonnieren. Das war es dann mit dem Chaosradio an dieser Stelle. Hier kommt dann Flo Heiler mit dem Live-Vertrag durch Punk-Musik um die Ohren werfen. Das ist quasi die erste, letzte Sendung des Jahres. Viel Spaß allen Chaoten. Wir hören uns im nächsten Jahr wieder. Vielen Dank, Nicolas, Maha und Elektra, für's hielsein.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und frohe Senden.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.